Magnus you've done it time and time
again against the absolute best players
in the world and you defended your title
here at the 2023 Champions test tour
finals
congratulations all
right all
right that is a very cool trophy
congratulations Magnus what do you
think it looks good uh is there um a
digital version as well or is it uh
there is an nft ver of this one as well
that is correct but I get to take this
one right you get to take the physical
one home magna's uh third consecutive
Champions chest title just incredible uh
what has this season been like what's
been the highlight for you I think the
Highlight certainly has been this
tournament um it's been it's been so
much fun the the format I think has
worked out great um bringing excitement
till uh till the very end also yeah it's
it's good to be here in a good
environment with uh basically all the
best um best players and
um I I I mean personally I'm very very
happy with the way the event ended uh
the very last game because it sort of
for me it sort of comes full circle
cuz when we had the first Champions
chess Tour
event um in 2020 I think that was when I
turned 30 and I lost to Wesley in the
fin that's exactly when sort of this
line uh in the Queen's Gambit that
Wesley played today was I mean I
wouldn't say it was invented it was a
little bit known but Wesley was kind of
the one who introduced it and made it
just very difficult to play D4 at all
like it's the Berlin of versus D4 so to
actually like win a game like decide the
Tour by winning a game against Wesley in
that line that's really comes full
circle for me oh that's fantastic cuz I
was thinking full circle would be 1 B3
the one the one goal you had left here
in the CCT 2023 so will that prepared
hard for it I thought I really thought
mag got to play it today well does that
mean we're going to see that next season
you have another goal you need to take
off next season Magnus yeah or probably
I should think more before I write down
M good point well Magnus um this is the
third consecutive one I I promis Wesley
I would ask you what will it take to
knock you off the throne I think several
people have been close uh and I did lose
a couple matches this uh this season as
well or more more than a more than a
couple so you know I um I'm still pretty
good so I still win some of the time but
I I don't win all the time so um you
know but um yeah um it's not going to be
um be easy anytime time soon I don't
think so yeah he's not going to make it
easy this guy he is your
2023 Champions chess T champ